[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement hebdo pour décrypter ensemble
l'actualité de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat avec vous Cathy Gilder bonjour
Alexandre et cette semaine nous
accueillons mode Gatel notre invité
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députés de
Paris on vous a vu récemment à côté de
François Bayrou pour les universités
d'été du MoDem vous êtes secrétaire
général du modèle on va voir avec vous
le feuilleton de la semaine et elle a
une cette semaine la réforme des
retraites il y aura bien une
concertation de plusieurs mois qui doit
aboutir à un projet de loi adopter à
d'ici la fin de l'hiver mais attention
Emmanuel Macron prévient en cas de
blocage des oppositions il menace de
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale
le début de l'examen du budget à 2023 au
Parlement le ministre de l'économie et
des finances Bruno Le Maire défend un
texte qui je cite protège le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
et puis le rapport choc de la délégation
au droit des femmes du Sénat qui
dénoncent les violences sexuelles dans
l'industrie de la pornographie
[Musique]
Question à la Une la réforme des
retraites aura-t-elle lieu on y voit un
peu plus clair pas de passage en force
du moins pas tout de suite mais un
projet de loi est annoncé pour l'hiver
avec le risque pour le gouvernement
d'une motion de censure des oppositions
dans ce cas prévient Emmanuel Macron il
n'hésitera pas éventuellement à
dissoudre le Parlement explication
Stéphanie DESPER
Emmanuel Macron temporise sur la méthode
et sur le calendrier je dis la première
ministre a annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas
de réforme des retraites dès cet automne
on fait le choix du dialogue et de la
concertation son allié le modem de
François Bayrou était vent debout contre
l'idée d'une réforme des retraites par
amendements dont le budget de la
Sécurité sociale même chose pour la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale mais
la réforme aura bien lieu d'ici l'été
prochain Emmanuel Macron il tient c'est
sa promesse de campagne alors Elisabeth
borne a précisé le calendrier un projet
de loi sera adopté avant la fin de
l'hiver les discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux et les partis vont
donc continuer jusqu'en décembre pour le
moment la nuit pêche et le RN campe sur
leur position au moment où il y a des
profits records dans notre pays et un
record de malheur aussi pour tant de
gens et des millions de gens dans notre
pays il est plus que temps d'augmenter
les salaires plutôt que l'âge de la
retraite et je pense que si Emmanuel
Macron ne redevient pas raisonnable il
le comprendra dans la douleur que ça
soit dans la rue dans l'hémicycle ou
dans les urnes la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est-ce que on est prêt à
sacrifier chaque année en trouvant des
sources économiques de bons sans dont on
pourrait parler 10 milliards d'euros
pour faire en sorte que les Français
puissent partir à la retraite dignement
sans avoir le dos cassé sans avoir les
bras cassés et nous nous défendons vous
le savez un départ à la retraite à 60
ans et 40 annuités pour tous ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20
ans
si jamais l'opposition parvient à voter
une motion de censure Emmanuel Macron
est très clair il y aura 10 solutions un
avertissement notamment pour les
républicains groupe charnière et en
théorie favorable à la réforme
maux de Gatel alors là c'est le scénario
qu'on a essayé d'imaginer pour l'instant
on n'y est pas parce que ce projet de
loi n'est pas encore déposé mais si
jamais il y avait un projet de loi et
une motion de censure qu'on se projet de
loi et ce qui est manuel Macron a raison
de brandir cette arme politique d'une
dissolution c'est quand même pas rien
oui mais la réforme des retraites c'est
pas rien non plus la réforme des
retraites c'est finalement un des
piliers le fondement de notre pacte
social et moi je défends l'idée qu'il
faut réformer cette cette
politique aujourd'hui pour deux raisons
la première raison c'est la pérennité du
système aujourd'hui on le sait le
système est en déficit il ne l'est pas
cette année mais il le sera à partir de
l'année prochaine et jusqu'à 2035 voire
2050 en fonction des prévisions
budgétaires
or c'est la base de cette solidarité
générationnelle dont on bénéficie depuis
quasi un siècle et donc il est important
de pérenniser ce système parce que c'est
un système de solidarité et puis il y a
un autre volet auquel nous sommes au
modem extrêmement attaché c'est faire en
sorte que ce régime soit plus juste or
aujourd'hui il ne l'est pas on va parler
de cette réforme des retraites sur le
fond mais d'abord une réaction quand
même sur cette menace de dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est quoi c'est un
coup de bluff l'idée c'est de faire peur
aux oppositions non je pense que c'est à
chacun de prendre ses responsabilités
est-ce qu'on a besoin d'une réforme des
retraites il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de parties qui répondent oui
d'ailleurs je rappelle que le régime
sous lequel nous sommes actuellement
c'est la loi Touraine donc réaliser sous
le gouvernement Hollande et on sait que
chaque année les sénateurs et les
députés les républicains déposent des
amendements visant à allonger la durée
de la
du temps de cotisation
donc que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités pour faire en sorte
qu'on réforme le système des retraites
de la manière la plus juste possible
alors il y avait une voix qui semblait
se dessiner une réforme par le biais
d'un amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dès
maintenant en réalité cela a suscité des
fous des oppositions notamment de
François Bayrou qui a visiblement
longuement discuté avec Emmanuel Macron
et finalement Emmanuel Macron a reculé
puisque il n'y aura pas de réforme par
voie d'amendement c'est une victoire
pour François Bayrou écoutez-moi ce qui
se soit une victoire de l'intérêt
général pour que cette réforme elle
aille à son terme parce que finalement
ce que ce que souhaitait François Bayrou
c'était qu'on puisse rassembler mettre
tout le monde autour de la table sur le
constat première victoire pour lui
puisqu'il n'y aura pas de passage en
force tout de suite on a besoin sur
cette réforme qui n'est pas qu'une
simple réforme financière le sujet c'est
pas simplement équilibrer les comptes le
sujet c'est quelle société on veut par
rapport au sujet du travail et au sujet
de la retraite et pour se faire on a
besoin besoin de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table les représentants des
partenaires sociaux les partis
politiques pour partager un constat
encertation c'est à dire pas de quoi on
a le temps on a le temps de faire en
sorte que les conditions de la
concertation soient réunies et après on
aura un texte parce que ce qu'il faut
bien avoir en tête c'est que cette
réforme elle est nécessaire moi je la
défense mais c'est une réforme à la fois
de société pour une société plus juste
donc finalement François Bayrou a eu
raison de défendre cette concertation et
de mettre son mécontentement sur la
place publique il n'était pas le seul à
demander que visiblement
il a été écouté tant mieux mais mais
c'est pas c'est pas la question qui a
gagné la question c'est est-ce qu'on
arrivera à avoir les meilleures
conditions possibles pour faire cette
réforme que j'estime nécessaire alors
sur le fond dans cette concertation
plusieurs sujets vont être discutés la
pénibilité elle est carrière longue mais
le report progressif de l'âge de départ
à la retraite à 64 ans 2027 puis à 65
ans
2031 ça et bien c'est non négociable
selon chef de l'État vous êtes d'accord
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut mettre
tous les sujets sur la table le sujet y
compris l'agilité carrière longue régime
spéciaux
hétérogénéité de la situation notamment
je pense au sujet de la discrimination
faite aux femmes il y a aucun hiérarchie
ce sont tous ces sujets qu'il faut qu'on
mette sur la table régime spéciaux
également et bien évidemment je pense
que nos concitoyens comprennent que dans
la mesure où l'espérance de vie augmente
il n'est pas illogique qu'on travaille
un petit peu plus d'ailleurs la réforme
Touraine a enclenché cette cette
démarche avec des trimestres
supplémentaires chaque année pour pour
les personnes
qui accélère le temps de cotisation et
l'âge de départ à la retraite donc je
pense que nos concitoyens peuvent tout à
fait le comprendre simplement on
n'arrive pas à l'âge du départ à la
retraite de la même manière quand on a
eu un travail pénible ou non et cette
dimension là pour moi elle est
absolument prioritaire il faut vraiment
qu'on mette ce sujet sur la table alors
elle avait déjà été porté cette réforme
de retraite en 2020 mais il y a eu
l'épidémie de covid qui la suspendu
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui dit que demain
si c'est présenté au Parlement il n'y
aura pas une crise problématiques graves
qui va balayer à nouveau la réforme
c'est possible ça aussi vous avez tout à
fait raison de le rappeler on avait
avancé sur un certain nombre de sujets
et notamment sur les carrières archives
sur la pénibilité lors de la discussion
près prépondément donc il faut qu'on
reparte aussi de ce qui a été fait à ce
moment-là et je pense vraiment qu'il y a
une vraie volonté partagé d'avancer sur
cette question bien évidemment les
Français le comprendront ils sont prêts
malgré leurs difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat ils sont prêts à une réforme de
la retraite à reculer l'âge de leur
départ là écoutez moi je fais partie
d'une génération qui me dit que sans
réforme des retraites je n'aurais pas de
retraite et je considère que c'est un
sujet que c'est un sujet vraiment une
société qu'il faut qu'on mette tous les
toutes les questions sur la table la
question de la pénibilité on est une la
question des carrières arrachées en est
une autre il faut vraiment qu'on arrive
à trouver un consensus sur à quel moment
on part en retraite en fonction de
l'hétérogénéité des situations et puis
il faut qu'on travaille aussi sur le
travail des seniors parce que on sait
aussi qu'en France on est moins bon que
la moyenne européenne sur le taux
d'emploi des seniors et sur cette
question aussi tout le monde doit
prendre sa part et en premier lieu les
entreprises parce que reculer l'âge du
départ à la retraite si c'est pour que
le chômage partiel soit la règle pour
les 60 65 ans n'a pas de sens alors vous
aurez beaucoup de travail en perspective
puisqu'il y a déjà un rendez-vous
incontournable de cet automne c'est
l'examen du budget au Parlement Bruno Le
Maire a présenté le texte au député au
sénateur ce budget 2023 a-t-il dit Marc
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte mais le
ministre a défendu un budget protecteur
écoutez Bruno Le Maire ainsi que ce qu'a
répondu cette semaine Pierre Moscovici
ce n'est pas un budget de rigueur ce
n'est pas un budget de facilité c'est un
budget responsable et protecteur dans
des temps de grande incertitude
et c'est un budget qui veut tenir le
juste équilibre entre la protection
nécessaire de nos compatriotes et le
rétablissement indispensable les
finances publiques concernant le
scénario macroéconique du gouvernement
le Haut Conseil considère que le taux de
croissance retenu pour 2023 paraît un
peu élevé en revanche nous estimons que
les prévisions d'inflation à 4,2% de
masse salariale dans les branches
marchandes à 5% sont quant à elle
plausibles alors à peine présenté un
mode Gatel ce budget a fait l'objet de
critiques de pas et d'autres de toutes
les oppositions qui ont dit tout le mal
qu'elle pensait de ce budget et vous au
modem vous dites quoi vous dites tout le
bien que vous pensez de ce budget vous
applaudissez Bruno Le Maire pour la
présentation de ce projet de loi de
finance 2023
ce projet de loi de finance il a quatre
objectifs d'abord continuer à protéger
les Français et ce projet de loi de
finances mais en oeuvre tout ce que nous
avons voté cet été c'est-à-dire
l'augmentation du point d'indice la
poursuite du bouclier tarifaire le
bouclier est tarifaire c'est
50 milliards dans le projet de loi de
finance 2023 c'est considérable et il
faut qu'on continue à protéger les
Français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'inflation et en France la
plus faible de la zone euro donc la
protection des Français
premier objectif deuxième objectif c'est
préparer l'avenir notamment sur la
question du régalien c'est
l'augmentation du budget de la défense
des forces armées c'est plus 1,3
milliards pour nos forces nos forces de
sécurité sur le terrain donc évidemment
ça va dans le bon sens il y a la
question de l'éducation et notamment la
revalorisation des salaires on le sait
il faut qu'on continue à travailler sur
cette question les enseignants ne sont
pas suffisamment payés et puis il y a le
retour sur une trajectoire
vers une un retour à 3% de déficit à
horizon 2027 parce qu'on a besoin de
débloquer des marges de manoeuvre en cas
de besoin et bien justement sur ce sujet
à la droite estime que ce budget n'est
pas assez ambitieux en terme d'économie
il faudrait réduire davantage les
dépenses compte tenu notamment du
contexte économique et du risque
d'inflation est-ce que ce budget est
assez raisonnable alors il est
raisonnable et puis j'écoutais Pierre
Moscovici dire que les que les
prévisions étaient
peut-être un petit peu ambitieuse moi
j'ai vu aussi les prévisions de l'OCDE
et du FMI qui partent équitable sur des
prévisions de croissance supérieures à
ce que le gouvernement a établi dans son
projet de loi de finances donc me
semble-t-il on est sur sur une sur un
étiage assez juste en matière de
croissance et en matière d'inflation
alors après nos amis républicains certes
ils veulent que nous baissions la
dépense publique mais moi quand je les
entends ils sont en permanence en train
de demander des dépenses supplémentaires
donc j'aimerais savoir où ils souhaitent
faire faire ses économies et puis on est
sur un sur un déficit de 5% c'était
aussi le déficit
prévu pour l'année 2022 la guerre en
Ukraine est passée par là et je trouve
que cette étage est relativement juste
alors si le gouvernement n'a pas la
majorité pour faire voter ce budget et
bien il pourrait cette fois utiliser
l'arme du 49 3 l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution qui permet de faire passer
un texte sans vote ce serait de nouveau
un passage en force est-ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne idée ou pas de menacer
dès maintenant du recours à un 49-3
alors il y a le sujet du 49 francs puis
le sujet de la méthode et je voudrais
saluer le travail qui a été fait
notamment par Gabriel Attal autour des
dialogues de Bercy de mettre autour de
la table l'ensemble des représentants
des formations politiques pour
travailler très en amont sur la question
du budget et d'ailleurs ça a été salué
par un certain nombre de représentants
parce parce que ce qui compte c'est
qu'on mette l'ensemble des propositions
sur la table et qu'on aille le plus loin
possible bien évidemment si un moment il
y a blocage il faudra en tirer toutes
les toutes les conséquences le 49-3
c'est un outil au service du
gouvernement et bien évidemment s'il
l'utilise ça n'est pas un passage en
force de mon point de vue alors il y a
une autre question qui se pose sur ce
budget c'est son ambition écologique
qu'on a vu tous les signes du
réchauffement climatique notamment sur
notre territoire cet été Bruno Le Maire
le reconnaît ce budget n'est pas assez
vert et ça fait partie des critiques de
la gauche vous aussi vous trouvez qu'il
y a un manque d'ambition écologique du
gouvernement avec ce budget alors moi je
salue deux choses c'est la mise en place
du fond vert pour les collectivités
territoriales 1,5 milliards d'euros ce
qui n'est pas rien et puis
l'augmentation de ma prime rénov le
budget dédié à l'amélioration enfin
l'accélération des rénovations
thermiques puisqu'on sait que le bâti
fait partie des premières sources de
démission de gaz à effet de serre et
puis il y a le plan vélo dont je me
réjouis aussi parce que je pense que il
faut qu'on
accélère sur sur ce sujet donc oui il
faut aller plus vite plus fort sur la
question de la transition écologique
mais moi je salue de véritables avancées
dans ce budget saluer beaucoup
d'avancées donc si on vous écoute quand
tu arriveras à Noël et qu'il faudra
voter l'ensemble de ce budget avec 49-3
ou pas la majorité pour raconter sur le
modèle tous les députés de modem pour
voter d'une seule voix ce budget écoutez
c'est nous on va continuer à travailler
et on a un certain nombre de
propositions à faire j'espère qu'elles
seront qu'elles seront entendues par le
gouvernement mais bien évidemment on
sera en soutien à ce à ce budget qui a
été présenté comme un budget de un
projet de loi de finances de protection
des Français et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment l'orientation qui est prise par
par ce projet de loi de finances
n'oublions pas qu'on est quand même dans
une situation extrêmement difficile pour
beaucoup beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qu'il faut continuer à avoir des aides
ciblées pour les plus fragiles et je
pense notamment au bouclier tarifaire et
au chèque énergie un mode hôtel on va
maintenant parler d'un rapport qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit cette semaine un
rapport sénatorial de la
au droit des femmes du Sénat sur
l'industrie de la pornographie après six
mois d'enquête d'audition de déplacement
sur le terrain et bien les sénateurs et
les sénatrices dénoncent les violences
sexuelles qui sont commises dans ce
milieu et puis les dangers que
représente les sites pornographiques
pour nos enfants Jérémy Hansmann
six mois de travaux des dizaines
d'heures d'auditions et un rapport
alarmant la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat dresse un tableau très
sombre de l'industrie du porno gangrené
selon les sénatrices par une violence
systémique envers les femmes l'industrie
pornographique aujourd'hui elle est
indissociable des violences 90% des
scènes sont montré son décès de violence
non simulées chantage emprise acte
sexuel forcé violent de soumission le
rapport dénonce des conditions de
tournage déplorables et des méthodes de
recrutement ciblant des femmes précaires
et fragiles
la culture du viol c'est soumettre les
femmes et ça s'apparente énormément
des pratiques devenues des normes et
diffusées aujourd'hui massivement via
les plateformes réseaux sociaux ou
messagerie privée chaque mois en France
19 millions de personnes visitent un
site pornographique pour les sénatrices
il y a donc urgence elle propose 23
recommandations pour imposer la lutte
contre les violences pornographiques
dans le débat public faciliter les
suppressions de contenu illicites et le
droit à l'oubli et protéger les mineurs
en appliquant la loi sur l'interdiction
d'accès parmi les mesures évoquées la
création d'un délit d'incitation à la
violence sexuelle qui pourrait
sanctionner les plateformes de diffusion
nous voulons que ce délit d'incitation à
la haine sexiste à la violence sexuelle
figure également dans le code pénal et
plus s'appliquer à des vidéos qui
montrent le viol l'humiliation les
violences sexuelles comme étant la norme
de la sexualité un rapport destiné aussi
à alerter les pouvoirs publics et
constitués selon les sénatrices une base
pour un futur texte de loi un mot de
Gatel qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce
rapport de vos collectionnatrices
d'abord je voudrais saluer leur travail
parce que c'était un travail
assez inédit
et et rassemblant finalement l'ensemble
de l'efficier politique autour de
constat absolument édifiant
sordide qui s'inscrivent aussi dans un
contexte judiciaire particulièrement
sordide pour moi il y a plusieurs choses
il y a la question il y a la question la
protection des enfants à travers la
restriction d'accès qui est absolument
indispensable
un chiffre
première image pornographique vu par les
enfants c'est à l'âge de 9 ans 9 ans
compte tenu l'image qui est véhiculée
des femmes dans ces dans cette
pornographie évidemment ça ne ça ne
laisse personne indemne et il faut tout
faire pour que les lois que nous avons
votées en 2020 et en 2022 puissent enfin
s'appliquer c'est-à-dire l'interdiction
strict de la pornographie pour les
mineurs et puis sur le sur l'aspect
l'aspect de l'image des femmes
véhiculées on est là quand même sur des
questions d'exploitation sexuelle de
traîtres de traite d'être humain
absolument épouvantable et il faut
évidemment renforcer les devoirs et les
obligations des plateformes parce
qu'aujourd'hui il s'affranchissent en
disant nous ne sommes que des diffuseurs
ça c'est absolument inacceptable
l'industrie l'industrie pornographique
et
gangrené par des pratiques ignobles et
il faut évidemment qu'on agisse vous ça
veut dire que c'est un peu une zone de
non-droit qui faut réglementer et ce
qu'il faut créer dans le code pénal un
nouveau délit d'incitation aux violences
sexuelles telles qu'on les a vu énumérés
dans dans le sujet alors à titre
personnel moi j'y suis favorable et je
suis favorable aussi parce qu'on
revienne sur la question éditeur
diffuseurs des plateformes c'est trop
facile de de faire de l'argent puisqu'on
parle quand même de milliards d'euros
lié à l'industrie pornographique au
niveau mondial souhaitant de jeunes
femmes en exploitant des jeunes femmes
et en disant je ne suis pas au courant
des conditions de tournage moi j'ai une
charte de déontologie si elle est pas si
si elle n'est pas respectée c'est pas
mon problème si c'est mon problème parce
qu'à partir du moment où je suis
diffuseur pour cette question des
plateformes elle n'est pas seulement
pour la question de la pornographie mais
il faut vraiment qu'on avance sur ce
sujet l'Union européenne a beaucoup
avancé sur la sur cette question il faut
désormais qu'on aille plus loin
notamment sur la question de la
pornographie c'est ça c'est un problème
international est-ce que nous en France
on a les moyens de combattre ces grandes
plateformes pornographiques qui sont des
multinationales je pense qu'on a les
moyens
l'interdiction de la diffusion à des
mineurs de moins de 18 ans
charge à nous de la faire respecter il y
a des il y a des il y a des logiciels
qui existent il y a des moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas de savoir comment est-ce
que les plateformes s'y prennent
simplement je ne veux plus que les
mineurs puissent avoir accès à ces
images vous imaginez le traumatisme pour
ces pour ses enfants quand ils sont
exposés à ce genre d'images de 9 ans dès
l'âge de 9 ans moins de 15 ans c'est
deux tiers des enfants qui ont vu des
films ou des extraits de films
pornographiques
évidemment ça construit une relation à
l'autre une relation à la femme
notamment qui n'est absolument pas celle
à laquelle la société doit aspirer donc
il faut qu'on agisse et qu'on agisse
fort et vraiment je voudrais saluer le
travail qui a été fait par ces quatre
sénatrice
on va juste une petite dernière question
est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction de la pornographie alors
ce n'est pas ce que demande ce rapport
mais ce qu'il faut l'encadrer à
davantage cette production
pornographique voir l'interdire alors
interdiction pour les mineurs c'est sûr
encadrement strict quand on quand on
voit ce chiffre 19 millions de Français
qui une fois par mois se rendent sur des
sur des plateformes l'interdiction est
un peu illusoire en revanche
l'encadrement extrêmement strict est
indispensable allez on va passer à
l'agenda de la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
[Musique]
d'abord à l'Assemblée nationale lundi
marquera l'ouverture de la session
ordinaire après la pause d'été s'ouvrira
avec un débat sur l'Ukraine sans vote et
sur les conséquences de la guerre pour
la France et puis mardi le rendez-vous
incontournable au grand moment de la vie
parlementaire le retour des questions au
gouvernement et puis au Sénat pour
l'ouverture de cette session ordinaire
et bien des débats seront organisés sur
l'état critique de certains services
publics et notamment celui de la justice
et des urgences hospitalières et puis
mercredi le Sénat examinera en
commission la proposition de loi de la
sénatrice centriste Valérie léthard qui
propose de créer une aide universelle
d'urgence aux victimes de violences
conjugales et maux de gatèle ont
souhaité vous interroger justement sur
cette proposition de loi alors pour bien
comprendre cette aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violences
conjugales prendrait d'un prêt à taux
zéro débloquer en 48 heures par la
Caisse d'Allocations familiale d'un
montant équivalent au RSA et verser
pendant trois mois le but c'est que les
femmes victimes qui décident de quitter
leur domicile ne se retrouve pas en
difficulté financière a priori vous si
vous étiez sénatrice votre Gatel vous la
voteriez cette proposition de loi
ecoutez je la voterai parce que les
femmes qui sont confrontées à des
situations de violence ont devant elle
une montagne de défis à relever d'abord
c'est de partir partir de leur
appartement parce que bien souvent c'est
à elle de partir malheureusement alors
il y a beaucoup de choses ont été faites
notamment en matière de d'hébergement
d'urgence à destination des femmes
victimes de violences et de leurs
enfants simplement c'est toujours
insuffisant et effectivement elles sont
confrontées lorsque elles ont pris la
décision mais elles sont confrontées à
des à des à des difficultés matérielles
et donc ce cette possibilité justement
de pouvoir compter sur un prêt Atos va
tout à fait dans le bon sens par rapport
aux enjeux qui sont les
une question sur les violences
conjugales de la part de certains
responsables politiques on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment notamment au sein
de la nupes l'alliance des gauches mode
Gatel est-ce que vous diriez je cite
qu'une gifle n'est pas égale au fait de
battre sa femme tous les jours c'est ce
qui a affirmé manuel Bompard des
dirigeants de la France insoumise dans
l'affaire Adrien ce qui a été mis en
retrait à qui s'est mis en retrait après
avoir reconnu avoir giflé sa femme on a
assisté ces derniers jours à
des propos à des réactions de la part de
deux parties notamment
profondément choquants
le pouvoir politique est pas exempt de
violence sexiste et sexuelle
comme d'autres milieux mais je pense que
le milieu politique
particulièrement par exemple simplement
la manière dont ont été gérées
pour moi est un fiasco total que ce soit
assez LFI ou chez les Verts et il me
semble que
on doit agir et que les partis
politiques ont plusieurs responsabilités
d'abord c'est la prévention bon
évidemment prévenir les violences
sexuelles et sexistes en leur sein c'est
l'accompagnement des victimes les
accompagner pour porter plainte et puis
c'est l'alerte mais moi je ne souhaite
pas que les partis politiques se
substituent à la justice pour autant il
faut pas non plus considérer qu'il ne se
passe rien et que le milieu politique
est totalement exempt de violence donc
il doit être exemplaire pour vous
il doit être exemplaire il doit mettre
tous les garde-fous il doit mieux
sensibiliser les responsables politiques
mais ne pas se substituer à la justice
et ne pas tomber dans le fiasco qu'on
auquel on a assisté ces derniers jours
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup mode Gatel d'y avoir participé
et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi